- I had to spoil my recess,
stop hanging out with the boys,
and go meet her in the recess
time because Mom said so.
(jazzy upbeat music)
- My dad dropped me and I saw these girls.
It was a girls' boarding school,
so I saw all of these girls
weeping and crying, and
my dad expected me to cry,
and I said, "Okay, now bye."
- The moment your parents leave
that's when you realize, "Oh
*@#!, people are crying here."
- First it was a bit difficult
because boys were a bit
confused if they should sit next to me.
- It was new and exciting
and you were away from home,
but then the homesickness kicks in.
- A teacher asked in the
class, very embarrassingly,
which she shouldn't have done saying,
"Who will be friends with Aditi?"
- Anytime somebody got her
period, it was a celebration.
So the principal would come to her
personally and congratulate her.
- There were several guys who would like
ask me out and it was very weird.
- We keep hearing random stories of women
trying funny experiments,
"Hey that test tube from
"the chemistry lab is
missing and you know why."
- There was a lot of hiding in bushes,
in the gym room, just everywhere.
- We used to get these bowls
of jelly, it was shit food.
So at the end we used to
trade with each other saying
"You give me your bowl of jelly and I will
eat your subji tomorrow afternoon."
- We used to have a 'duck shop'.
So like it was junk food and
chocolates and everything.
- Rats was an undercover publication
and there was an entire
satire written about teachers
and how teachers fight
for positions within
departments to become
heads of departments.
Nobody knows until now
who actually published it.
- Two friends of mine were doing it
in the the gym on these mats and the boy
jumped off and the girl tried to jump off
but there was a trampoline there
and she jumped off the trampoline
and they thought they got away with it
except she jumped on the trampoline
so she came back up and the teacher saw.
- I think it's just, friends don't change,
their definitions in
your life don't change,
you change as a person.
- My boarding school girlfriends are still
closer to me than, I
mean I have best friends
here as well but it's not the same.
- And it's like, you know,
they're like my sisters
or my brothers, we were that
close, it was more like family.
- I think we were under
the false belief that
we would meet each other all again.
We didn't realize the importance of
goodbye and I think that was good.
(jazzy upbeat music)